i love people who go all out and the
actress taraji p henson is certainly one
of those people she told in style that
during lockdown she built herself a full
beauty salon at home
complete with a real cash register
that's the part
by the way that was the detail i love
too she says it's her own little world
and it makes her feel good and it's
stocked with
her tph by taraji hair care line
and she hosts her instagram series from
the salon sharing tips on how to nourish
and protect your hair and scalp thoughts
i think it's really fun that she put a
salon in her house
the cashier the register makes me laugh
i hope she takes her own personal check
but then i thought what would i put in
my house like if i was you
to really take a swing like that what
would you do thought about it
it would be a movie theater with a soda
fountain machine
you know what i mean i love fountain
soda i like taraji i'm actually on board
with this kind of cuckoo i like this
about you and i'd like to come to your
salon
it's cute and you know this covet has
been tough on everybody and we couldn't
go to the salon
so put one in your house and you know we
talked about during the whole pandemic
the rise and comfy casual style
so if you're dreading shedding those
sweats well i have great news for you
refinery29 reports parachute pants
are back hey drew what time is it hammer
time
yeah remember these it's an update on
the old hammer pants we all know and we
love
drew am i going to see you in hammer
pants
no all i know is that my inner thighs
don't need that material rubbing
together making a loud sound
like like no thank you and parachute
it doesn't feel good next to the skin
it's like
why do you want that material on your
body i don't know i just thought you'd
find like some fun in the
nostalgic nature of it but do you like
them
are you gonna wear them i didn't say i
like them or that i was gonna
wear them but i like that people are
wearing them all right
next if you're looking for a way to feel
more awake and energized in the morning
you might want to try that rise up
method
rossi i saw what this is everybody
get ready i was really intrigued i have
to say
it kind of was really revelatory so
huffpost reports that rise up was
developed by
sleep scientists and studies show it can
make your mornings feel
less groggy okay it's an acronym
r is for resist the urge
for the snooze button um i is for
increase your physical activity in the
first hour you are awake
rossi yeah i do this i get up i'm a i'm
a morning person
i'm like belle and beauty and the beast
good day sure i say hi
it's annoying smelling baked brad and
the whole night
in my basket s is for shower or get that
cold water onto your face and hands
i agree with that a little mm-hmm um
okay
e is for expose yourself to sunlight
wait for it to sunlight yes
um u is for upbeat music
yes it would be fun to put on a little
donna summer get going
i need to get on this rise up program p
is for
phone a friend that surprises me me too
maybe they're on uh who wants to be a
millionaire
i used to love that show of course it's
like so major
well if you're looking for a good way to
get that blood flowing in the morning
there's a new way to make
fitness fun when you think it's time to
work out it's like eye roll
well now enjoy apartment therapy reports
fitness dice will gamify your workout
gamify it
it comes with dice that you roll out to
get a different workout every single day
so i have some here
six of the dice show you different
fitness moves that only require your
body weight no special weights or bands
needed
and the seventh dice tells you how many
reps to do got it so one will say number
one will say the exercise to do let's
throw it out
it goes like this oh um drew we're gonna
try it we're gonna do 10
uh 10 squats all right the last time we
did squats
here on the news desk i pulled my back
because i'm speaking of
seniors we can do this drew this is our
exercise for the day all right 10 squats
10 squats that's this already we'll do
it together where do your hands go like
this
i don't know what what wait
one you know with squats my trainer
katrina rini always says that you're
supposed to put like the weight in your
heel
uh-huh four um i have to say this
i really am into this i stopped counting
okay i did two
but they kind of look like sex coma
sutra dice also
well that was my question if they came
in um
funsies ones yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
another one
um okay 15 reps of um what is he doing
oh let's do a different one it's like
he's like literally all it did
was this hold on this one's good um
try this one okay okay 15 of this
all right